was mich sehr erstaunt und erschrocken
hat ist das doch sehr viele leute aus
dem nahen umfeld einen dann im rücken
kehren also kann man es vorher der der
held wenn investoren kommen aber dann
wenn es dann zu ende ist dann ist es
auch bei einigen freunden wo ich
wirklich auch sehr überrascht war die
schon lange vor der gründung von
bekannte aus gebieten mit der
freundschaft oliver lind ist mit seinem
vater pleite gegangen hat einen
digitalen schlüssel erfunden mit dem
lassen sich per smartphone autos öffnen
herkömmliche wagen können damit
nachgerüstet werden
für seine innovation heimste er mehrere
preise ein
trotzdem gingen nach vier jahren das
geld aus und das hat ihn gezeichnet
er war ein ziemlicher schock auf einen
freitagabend im november wo wir erfahren
haben dass das investment was eigentlich
schon in trockenen tüchern war und die
verträge ausgehandelt werden das nicht
kommen wird wo sich jemand spontan um
entschieden hat und dann ging es los
dass man versucht hat auf schnellstem
wege zu gucken gibt es noch
möglichkeiten irgendwoher geld zu
bekommen
anderthalb millionen euro hat er
verbrannt geld vom server betreiber von
investoren und bekannten die mitarbeiter
musste er entlang auf messen die
firmengründer wird kaum über das
scheitern gesprochen hier herrscht
grenzenlose optimismus obwohl neun von
zehn startup in deutschland
erfahrungsgemäß mit glück scheiterte
oliver längst selbst schweigt lieber
darüber
doch der wirtschaftsingenieur geht offen
mit einem fehlschlag um
wir hatten das produkt für einen echten
kunden bedarf anpassen müssen wir haben
zu lange in die richtung entwickelt in
der wir dachten dass der kunde haben
möchte und haben zu spät gemerkt dass
der markt eigentlich einer ganz anderen
ecke führen fliegt für sie votieren wie
man sagt
die strategie wechseln wollten tobias
zum bild ist sogar zweimal gescheitert
trotzdem meint man ihn nicht in der
geschäftswelt meine kunden welche farbe
die ich hätten was weit und dient nicht
als schicksal oder also die angst
unbegründet also dass man auch mal auch
neue wege im professionellen bereich ist
unbegründet im gesellschaftlichen ist
schon so dass ich von freunden und
familie auf die frage bekommen also mit
gescheitert und berät gibt andere also
wissen unternehmen gescheitert und berät
andere unternehmen das geht doch nicht
aber geht der größte
solche erfahrungen neben jungen menschen
die angst vor der selbstständigkeit mehr
mut erfordert erstmal angefangen und
dann kann man ja weiter gucken wie es
läuft und vielleicht dann doch die ihren
wagen erst eingehen kann wissen die
leute leben noch ein offenbar sind auf
einen blick habe daraus gelernt
geldaufnahme betrifft und versuchen so
wenig wie wirklich ganz
durchhaltevermögen bei dann kann man
sich ihre wege
oliver lück hat eine neue firma
gegründet mittlerweile kann er auch
bürotüren digital öffnet die neustadt
wagte er in einem berliner
gründerzentrum finanziert unter anderem
mit den ersparnissen seiner mutter 350
euro miete zahlt ihr hier das budget
doch sollte mal dass sie schreibt eine
neue firma von anfang an schwarze zahlen
auch wirklich weiter man beruhigt
schlafen kann sein kann auch in zwei
drei monaten muss ich mir nicht die
sorgen machen wo kommt das geld her um
die miete die mitarbeiter ihre gehälter
zu bezahlen
das ist insofern deutlich entspannter
für das weitere wachstum will er
demnächst den nachbarraum anmieten er
will drei zusätzliche mitarbeiter
einstellen
zu den kunden gehören inzwischen ein
autovermieter ebenso wie die deutsche
telekom die pleite stecke noch immer in
den knochen doch den traum vom
erfolgreichen eigenen unternehmen
scheint nun endlich wahr zu werden